we were at the grocery store the other
day and I saw Pearl Milling Company
breakfast syrup or whatever it used to
be Aunt Jemima and then on the bottle it
says formerly Aunt Jemima new name same
Great Taste and I thought two things one
is it still says Aunt Jemima on the
bottle they I don't understand her off
right they got rid of her put the name
still down on the bottom so you can
still see it you know what it is and
then the funny thing was I turned her
around took a picture of the ingredients
and I'm like same great recipe and the
recipe is high fructose corn syrup like
it's just total garbage not real maple
syrup but I'm just that's a funny Point
like everybody knows Coke is bad but
they can relate to it like I'm drinking
it anyway